des chaises pour dix jeunes femmes après
avoir donné la parole aux hommes dans
illuminations ahmed madani constitue le
deuxième volet de son aventure face à
leur destin
les deux spectacles vivants sont
inspirés des récits de ces jeunes issus
de quartiers populaires pour mettre la
vie moderne sur le plateau au premier
jour de répétition la page blanche
c'est le principe est on dialogue qu'est
ce qu'on fait eh ben on se raconte des
histoires on est sur un don et un contre
dont le metteur en scène a mis deux ans
pour réunir son casting
moi je m'appelle année ça j'ai 28 ans je
ne pense pas représenter une catégorie
de personnes en tout cas pas les
pénélopes et tenir et femmes voilées
parmi elles anissa à oreille est
originaire de montigny le bretonneux
après avoir joué dans une centaine de
théâtre dont une tournée en suisse
revenir à saint quentin en yvelines a un
goût particulier
en fait c'est chez moi j'ai vu je peux
aller n'importe où dans le monde
mais là où j'ai grandi c'est ici donc
forcément il ya une forte émotion non
professionnels à l'origine elles jouent
chantent dansent et livrent toute leur
puissance
ces deux années dans la compagnie madani
leur ouvre de nouvelles voies
ça m'a donné vraiment envie de continuer
à creuser en moi et là je me suis mise à
réaliser un documentaire qui
primé par la fondation france
télévisions qui s'appelle les danses de
l'adar un troisième volet réunissant
hommes et femmes devrait voir le jour
d'ici 2020 son nom incandescence vient
tout juste d'être décidé par ahmed
madani